The oldest cultures
are not human.
They're from the ocean.
40 million years ago
before we walked upright,
before we sparked fire -
Whales evolved
to build relationships
in the dark.
I'm trying to start
a conversation -
- is the most basic way
you can say it.
I'm trying to put a speaker
in the ocean
and talk to a whale and
hope it talks back.
Starting playback.
If this work is successful
it would be the first
experiment
where we have engaged
in a dialogue
with a humpback whale.
People have been studying
humpback songs
for 40 or 50 years.
And still
no one really knows
why they sing.
Something different
is happening here.
The study has a high
probability of failure.
We have only a month
to survey at least 30 whales.
It is so hard to interpret
the language
of the natural world.
To listen
and to understand
what it's saying
to itself.
That is of the same proportion
as pointing all of our
satellites skyward
and listening for a sign
from outer space.
Pretty cool.
That's pretty cool.
They're talking back to you.
Studying whale culture
might be more about
glimpsing
something of ourselves.
How we can connect differently
a million years from now.